.
Un fléau qui coûte cher,
très cher. Mathieu Dion.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Des hôpitaux, des
municipalités et des grandes
organisations comme la STM
ont récemment été pris
en otage, après l'infiltration
d'un rançongiciel dans
leur système informatique,
un logiciel malveillant qui
bloque l'accès aux données.
Les pirates menacent ensuite
de diffuser les informations
exfiltrées et exigent une somme
d'argent pour les restaurer.
Comme le recommandent
les autorités, la STM a refusé
de payer la rançon de près
de 3 millions de dollars
en cryptomonnaie.
Mais Radio-Canada a appris que
l'incident d'octobre a mené
à une réclamation à son assureur
de 5 millions de dollars pour
les frais d'expertise et heures
consacrées par ses employés
à la gestion de la crise.
La Société a décliné notre
demande d'entrevue, jugeant
le sujet encore trop sensible.
- La solution, c'est la solution
la plus complexe, c'est la seule
qui va vraiment marcher à terme,
mais c'est l'éducation
des utilisateurs.
- Flare Systems aide
les organisations à protéger
leur environnement numérique
externe des cybercriminels,
mais les rançongiciels vont bien
souvent s'introduire subtilement
à la suite de l'ouverture
par un employé d'un fichier
joint à un courriel.
MATHIEU LAVOIE
pdg, Flare Systems
- C'est le pont-levis qui est
descendu de la forteresse du
château et oups! l'accès est
donné par cette personne-là.
- Le Bureau d'assurance
du Canada perçoit bien l'ampleur
du phénomène, notamment
en raison de l'implantation
massive du télétravail.
Il rapporte qu'en 2020,
les assureurs ont dû
débourser près de 4 dollars
en indemnisation pour chaque
dollar de primes perçues
pour la couverture cyber-
responsabilité
VINCENT GAUDREAU, V-P,
Gaudreau Assurances
- C'est sûr qu'à long terme,
ce n'est pas soutenable pour
n'importe quelle compagnie
d'assurance.
- Les primes en cyberassurance
augmenteraient actuellement
de 10 à 20 % dans
certains dossiers.
- C'est sûr qu'il va y avoir
des conséquences sur
le marché inévitablement
dans les prochains mois,
les prochaines années.
- Le stockage de Montréal
est en effet victime
d'une attaque-rançon.
- Pendant ce temps, des moyens
sont mis en place au Québec pour
se défendre contre ces attaques,
avec des jeunes pousses
au front.
PASCAL LEBLANC
PDG, Mantle Technology
- Le statu quo ne peut plus
durer et c'est le temps
justement de se tourner vers
les technologies émergentes.
- Mantle propose une solution
utilisée par les cryptomonnaies,
la chaîne de blocs,
afin de protéger les données.
- C'est-à-dire de les passer
dans le déchiqueteur, puis
de les stocker à des endroits
de stockage différents. Donc
advenant le cas qu'un pirate
vient mettre un rançongiciel
sur un endroit de stockage,
c'est pas grave parce qu'on est
capable reconstruire
la donnée avec seulement
les blocs disponibles.
- Au Groupe RHEA, qui offre
une technologie bouclier
à de grandes organisations,
son président estime
qu'il est temps de mettre
à profit les capacités
du Québec en cybersécurité.
ANDRÉ SINCENNES,
PDG, Groupe RHEA
- Sans l'apport du gouvernement,
il est difficile au niveau
des plus petites entreprises
de bien se préparer.
- Mais comme avec une police
d'assurance, il est toujours
difficile d'investir dans
ce qu'on ne voit pas, jusqu'à
ce que le malheur frappe.
Ici Mathieu Dion,
Radio-Canada, M